Look at anger itself.
It looks very menacing,
like a billowing monsoon cloud or thunderstorm.
We think we could sit on the cloud,
but if you go there, it's just mist.
Likewise, if you look at the thought of anger,
it will vanish like frost under the morning sun.
If you do this again and again, the propensity,
the tendencies for anger to arise again
will be less and less each time you dissolve it.
And, at the end, although it may rise,
it will just cross the mind,
like a bird crossing the sky without leaving any track.
So this is the principal of mind training.
Now, it takes time,
because it took time for all those faults in our mind, the tendencies, to build up,
so it will take time to unfold them as well.
But that's the only way to go.
Mind transformation -- that is the very meaning of meditation.
It means familiarization with a new way of being,
new way of perceiving things,
which is more in adequation with reality,
with interdependence, with the stream and continuous transformation,
which our being and our consciousness is.
So, the interface with cognitive science,
since we need to come to that, it was, I suppose, the subject of --
we have to deal in such a short time -- with brain plasticity.
The brain was thought to be more or less fixed.
All the nominal connections, in numbers and quantities,
were thought, until the last 20 years,
to be more or less fixed when we reached adult age.
Now, recently, it has been found that it can change a lot.
A violinist, as we heard, who has done 10,000 hours of violin practice,
some area that controls the movements of fingers in the brain changes a lot,
increasing reinforcement of the synaptic connections.
So can we do that with human qualities?
With loving kindness, with patience, with openness?
So that's what those great meditators have been doing.
Some of them who came to the labs,
like in Madison, Wisconsin, or in Berkeley,
did 20 to 40,000 hours of meditation.
They do, like, three years' retreat, where they do meditate 12 hours a day.
And then, the rest of their life, they will do three or four hours a day.
They are real Olympic champions of mind training.
(Laughter)
This is the place where the meditators -- you can see it's kind of inspiring.
Now, here with 256 electrodes.
(Laughter)
So what did they find?
Of course, same thing.
The scientific embargo --
a paper has been submitted to "Nature," hopefully, it will be accepted.
It deals with the state of compassion, unconditional compassion.
We asked meditators, who have been doing that for years and years,
to put their mind in a state where there's nothing but loving kindness,
total availability to sentient being.
Of course, during the training, we do that with objects.
We think of people suffering, of people we love,
but at some point, it can be a state which is all pervading.
Here is the preliminary result,
which I can show because it's already been shown.
The bell curve shows 150 controls,
and what is being looked at
is the difference between the right and the left frontal lobe.
In very short, people who have more activity
in the right side of the prefrontal cortex
are more depressed, withdrawn.
They don't describe a lot of positive affect.
It's the opposite on the left side:
more tendency to altruism,
to happiness, to express, and curiosity and so forth.
So there's a basic line for people. And also, it can be changed.
If you see a comic movie, you go off to the left side.
If you are happy about something, you'll go more to the left side.
If you have a bout of depression, you'll go to the right side.
Here, the -0.5 is the full standard deviation
of a meditator who meditated on compassion.
It's something that is totally out of the bell curve.
So, I've no time to go into all the different scientific results.
Hopefully, they will come.
But they found that -- this is after three and a half hours
in an fMRI,
it's like coming out of a space ship.
Also, it has been shown in other labs --
for instance, Paul Ekman's labs in Berkeley --
that some meditators are able, also,
to control their emotional response more than it could be thought.
Like the startle experiments, for example.
If you sit a guy on a chair
with all this apparatus measuring your physiology,
and there's kind of a bomb that goes off,
it's such an instinctive response that,
in 20 years, they never saw anyone who would not jump.
Some meditators, without trying to stop it,
but simply by being completely open,
thinking that that bang is just going to be a small event like a shooting star,
they are able not to move at all.
So the whole point of that is not, sort of, to make, like,
a circus thing of showing exceptional beings who can jump, or whatever.
It's more to say that mind training matters.
That this is not just a luxury.
This is not a supplementary vitamin for the soul.
This is something that's going to determine
the quality of every instant of our lives.
We are ready to spend 15 years achieving education.
We love to do jogging, fitness.
We do all kinds of things to remain beautiful.
Yet, we spend surprisingly little time taking care of what matters most --
the way our mind functions --
which, again, is the ultimate thing
that determines the quality of our experience.
Now, compassion is supposed to be put in action.
That's what we try to do in different places.
Just this one example is worth a lot of work.
This lady with bone TB, left alone in a tent,
was going to die with her only daughter.
One year later, how she is.
Different schools and clinics we've been doing in Tibet.
And just, I leave you with the beauty of those looks
that tells more about happiness than I could ever say.
(Laughter)
And jumping monks of Tibet.
Flying monks.
Thank you very much.